y
[Música]
bienvenidos a este avance informativo de
francés 24
comenzamos en israel que estaría a punto
de poner fin a dos años de crisis
política y evitar un quinto llamado a
las urnas
de paso acabaría con 12 años de benjamin
netanyahu en el poder la oposición logró
un acuerdo para formar una coalición
gracias a la inclusión a última hora de
un partido árabe
de ratificarse en el parlamento dentro
de los próximos 12 días la coalición
estaría liderada por el
ultranacionalista religioso naftalí
bennett y el centrista laico yair lapid
[Aplausos]
uno de los barcos más grandes de la
armada de irán se hundió este miércoles
después de incendiarse frente al puerto
de husky en el golfo de humana la
televisión estatal iraní informó que
alrededor de 400 personas que se
encontraban a bordo resultaron ilesas
sin embargo no dio mayores detalles
sobre el incidente ocurrido en una zona
fluvial sensible el golfo de humana que
se conecta con el estrecho de ormuz por
donde pasa alrededor de una quinta parte
del petróleo del mundo
y en colombia avanza una nueva jornada
de paro nacional en medio de un
estancamiento de las conversaciones
entre el comité nacional del paro y el
gobierno para poner fin a más de un mes
de protestas en diferentes ciudades
manifestantes siguen expresando su
rechazo al ejecutivo y a la violencia
policial nuestro periodista luís luís
muñoz estuvo en las marchas
colombia cumple un mes de paro nacional
estamos en bogotá en la capital en una
de las salidas sur de la ciudad que los
manifestantes han renombrado como portal
resistencia parece que después de un mes
de protestas todavía está lejos la
salida al conflicto y es que el gobierno
y el comité nacional de paro todavía no
han iniciado negociaciones ya que las
posturas están muy lejanas el ejecutivo
de iván duque pide a los manifestantes
que levanten bloqueos como éste que
rigen en todo el país mientras que el
comité nacional de paro pide al gobierno
que desmilitariza ciudades como cali en
este contexto parece difícil saber cómo
va a evolucionar estas protestas que no
están siendo masivas en un punto
concreto sino que se reparten en muchos
tanto en bogotá como en colombia vamos
ahora a méxico que se prepara para las
elecciones más grandes de su historia en
las que hay 20.000 cargos públicos en
juego y que son vistas como un referendo
de la gestión del presidente andrés
manuel lópez obrador ya que su partido
podría perder el control de la cámara de
diputados
al menos 88 candidatos y aspirantes han
sido asesinados desde el inicio del más
reciente proceso electoral por lo que la
comisión nacional de derechos humanos
expresó su preocupación por los actos de
violencia
los líderes de 40 de las naciones más
ricas del mundo se comprometieron hoy a
aportar 2400 millones de dólares a la
campaña global para distribución de
vacunas en los países más pobres el
acuerdo fue alcanzado durante la cumbre
de la iniciativa kóvacs y pretende
ayudar a financiar la entrega de 1.800
millones de vacunas entre las naciones
en vías de desarrollo
y en medio de este debate sobre si las
dosis sobrantes en las naciones más
ricas deberían donarse a países con
menos recursos
el presidente francés emmanuel macrón
anunció que a partir del 15 de junio los
menores de entre 12 y 18 años podrán
acceder a la vacunación macrón también
informó que esto es posible debido a que
el 50 por ciento de los adultos
franceses ha recibido al menos una dosis
del fármaco y los suministros han
aumentado
hasta aquí este avance informativo
quédense con nosotros